[Música]
seguramente para la mayoría de todos
nosotros la estación del año que más nos
gustó y más anhelamos en la primavera se
auto ahora cómo es que nos damos cuenta
que la primavera está llegando solamente
cada una de ustedes va a tener una
percepción distinta es cuando la
primavera está por venir tal vez algunos
perciban los días más lindos como ahora
el calorcito los días donde una puesta
al afuera tal vez otros vean los brotes
verdes de las plantas o tal vez otros el
aroma de las flores no de sus jardines y
otros tal vez un poco más observadores
puedan ver que las golondrinas han
vuelto un año más
todas estas percepciones que les comento
del mundo natural de naturaleza nos
parece absolutamente normales cotidianas
que no nos llaman la atención
sin embargo cuando descubrimos las
percepciones que tienen otros animales
del mundo natural nos huele a la cabeza
nos parece absolutamente increíble y
déjeme contarle solamente una a modo de
ejemplo de visuales las golondrinas
solamente ustedes escucharon hablar que
las golondrinas como todas las aves
migratorias
capaces de guiarse en su viaje
migratorio con el campo magnético de la
tierra para la pregunta es cómo hacen
eso cómo es que pueden percibir el campo
cañete de la tierra déjenme contarles
cómo hacen en las células de los ojos de
estas aves tiene un pigmento que tiene
una particularidad ese pigmento ese
pigmento tiene un mineral de hierro y
magnetita es como un micro imán ese imán
se alinea con el campo magnético de la
tierra y produce una magia cambia la
estructura del pigmento al cambiar esa
estructura las células de los que
empiezan a mandar señales al cerebro o
sea lo que le estoy diciendo lisa y
llanamente es que las aves migratorias
pueden ver el campo magnético de la
tierra la pueden percibir y pueden saber
si se están dirigiendo hacia los polos o
sea el ecuador esto es una forma
absolutamente increíble que tienen de
percibir es un mundo natural y es
imposible para nosotros imaginarnos cómo
es eso como es que puede ver el campo
magnético como sería darlo y eso es lo
que nos asombra uno dispara infinidad de
preguntas el por qué tiene esos animales
esa percepción tan fina
y porque nosotros en definitiva no
podemos percibir de esa manera y la idea
es con ustedes trata de entender estas
preguntas que nos hacemos y vamos a
empezar por los animales les voy a pedir
algo muy simple tratemos de pensar
hábitos y costumbres normales que uno
observa en los animales yo las vi hace
una lista de algunas ustedes pueden
pensar otras y van a ver que hemos
encontrado un patrón común en todas
estas conductas
por ejemplo los animales comen los
animales duermen los animales buscan
refugio para las inclemencias del tiempo
migran cuidan territorios pelean por
territorios buscan pareja crían hijos
etcétera cosas absolutamente normales
que todo el mundo puede observar no hace
falta ser un científico cierto ahora
vamos a encontrar un patrón en todas
estas conductas vamos a ver qué va y
conductas que están asociadas con la
supervivencia y con la reproducción por
ejemplo comer si no se come no se
sobrevive y aquellos animales que comen
pueden que ir a su descendencia
supervivencia reproducción lo mismo que
la migración los animales que emigran es
para reproducirse o para escapar del
invierno y sobrevivir esta idea en la
biología no es nueva del siglo 19 darwin
se utilizó para proponer su teoría de la
evolución por selección natural
básicamente lo que dice darwin es que
aquellos animales e individuos que están
adaptadas un medio ambiente son capaces
de dejar una mayor cantidad
descendientes o sobrevivir más traducido
a estos ejemplos de las conductas
podemos ver que aquellos animales que
son más eficientes en conseguir alimento
son más capaces de sobrevivir más
capaces de dejar ir mayor cantidad
descendientes lo mismo con la migración
lo mismo que la capacidad de defender un
territorio obtener parejas
ahora todos estos conceptos hacen que
nosotros entendamos por qué los animales
pareciendo una manera tan aguda a su
medio ambiente porque está la selección
natural de atrás constantemente
seleccionando y empujando los animales
que se adapten a través de sus sentidos
al medio ambiente o simplemente no se
reproducen o simplemente no sobrevive
ahora qué ocurre con nosotros somos tan
distintos al reino animal al resto del
reino animal
pensémoslo con la misma lógica hagamos
una listita de las actividades y
costumbres que tenemos nosotros y
tratemos de ver cuán diferentes somos yo
voy a hacer al nombre de algunas ustedes
pueden pensar otras y vamos a llegar al
mismo punto nos levantamos desayunamos
trabajamos hacemos deportes nos juntamos
con amigos criamos a nuestros hijos
dormimos y ahora fíjense acá que cuando
tratamos de catalogar estas actividades
como el eje mencioné recién con
funciones de reproducción y
supervivencia vamos a encontrar que es
muy similar porque trabajan ustedes
para llenar la heladera cierto para que
ya su familia reproducción supervivencia
porque usted practica el deporte van a
escuchar música están aquí escuchando me
miran porque me gusta porque me hace
sentir bien porque tiene una mejor
calidad de vida
o sea repercute de una forma en su
supervivencia y hablar de que todos
soñamos con nuestro príncipe o princesa
azul reproducción criar hijos si en ese
sentido no somos muy distintos del resto
de los animales pero sin embargo no
percibimos de la misma forma que ellos
perciben el mundo natural entonces
tenemos que buscar otra cosa y esa cosa
es la cultura la cultura actúa como un
paraguas como una barrera para que la
selección natural no esté detrás nuestro
constantemente empujándonos para
percibir constantemente el miedo donde
vivimos sano no actúa de manera tan
cruel con nosotros como el resto gracias
a la cultura o sea ustedes no tienen
miedo de caminar por la calle por la
playa o salir de este auditorio y con un
animal vaya atrás de ustedes y se los
coma usted no se le vaya bien en el
próximo invierno
usted necesitan
un territorio cuidarlo y protegerlo
frente a otros con un riesgo físico y de
su salud ustedes necesitan marcar un
territorio con orina y liberar feromonas
para atraer pareja quiero creer que no
lo hacen
- más además no funciona me dijo un
amigo premio y para eso está la cultura
la cultura sc ese escudo que hace que la
selección natural no nos llegue de esa
manera tan cruda como les ya recién
ahora también la cultura produjo estos
efectos en nuestra nuestra vida es esta
atenuación de los sentidos pues ya no
necesitamos los sentidos para detectar
el predador para detectar el invierno se
va a hacer crudo para buscar alimento
etcétera por lo tanto no percibimos en
detalle y de manera aguda nuestro
entorno y también nos generó otra falsa
concepción que es que la naturaleza de
hecho si la escribimos y intercambiamos
ideas de lo que es y lo que no es
solamente todo el mundo más relatar que
es un lugar inhóspito alejado fuera de
toda actividad humana fuera del humano y
fuera
nuevamente ahí nos estamos alejando de
algo que nos rodea y nos permite vivir a
ver si no fuese por la naturaleza no
tendrían alimentos no tendrían la ropa
que tienen no estarían sentados en
asociaciones de madera por ejemplo
naturaleza cuando sienten frío calor
cuando respiran esto eso produce viene o
es el producto entidades biológicas que
nos rodea constantemente por lo tanto la
cultura nos generó esta falsa idea de
que nosotros estamos por fuera de la
naturaleza y que nuestra cultura nuestra
vida está viviendo ajena a ella por lo
tanto tenemos que entender que es algo
más cotidiano y que está alrededor
nuestro por más que no lo podemos
percibir muchas gracias